battlefield one is finally here in all
of its mud and bloody glory for all to
take in
we finally gotten our hands on a
finished product and to kick things off
here our top six newest features added
to battlefield one we've seen Zeppelin's
two heavily armoured trains in the past
but now the third behemoth is here the
dreadnought this battleship is ready to
sink your dreams of victory with one of
its four heavy cannons that are powerful
enough to level capture points on sight
followed by also having anti-infantry
guns mounted on its side it's perfect to
support infantry pushing up the enemy
beachhead it took all of my grenades a
few heavy cannon shells from my base
defenses a few warplanes to slow this
ship down even then it will leave its
mark on the field and in your soldiers
Minds even as it sinks into the sea
speaking of boats returning from bf4 our
attack boats to combat both dreadknots
and land-based fortresses these fast and
agile boats are excellent for covering
long distances allowing yourself to
flank your enemies also when driving
you'll have two torpedoes I can do heavy
damage to other boats and/or ships in
your sights
sporting heavy machine guns on both
sides and in front of your boat for your
passengers this thing is ready to take
on the high seas for any mission you see
fit some new equipment has returned from
the days of bf4 such as the motor for
the support class with three different
types of ammunition and a surprising
high splash damage upon hitting its
target these motors are the go-to
weapons for launching a full frontal
assault on well defended enemy targets
able to select your target area on the
mini-map made this super useful in the
urban map of arms where enemy soldiers
hided in bombed-out houses all over the
place this is the go-to weapon to use to
take out pesky enemies hiding in those
houses
a new century kid has made its way in
the form of a to magazine SMG that can
drop your foes faster than you can blink
just like it's heavy armored cousins the
flamethrower and the heavy machine gun
this kit gives you full protection and
knights in shining armor look along with
a weapon that is just too powerful to be
true just 5 rounds from its 25 round
magazine can drop any player regardless
of the character he plays this kind of
firepower helped lead me to a 69 kill 2
to death ratio and just one round let's
just say my opponents weren't too happy
about getting killed so quickly but hey
it's war and it sucks for them
the maps in battlefield ones final build
offer a ton of variety from fighting in
the snowy mountains in Italy to the lush
full force of the Argonne to the
sunsetting ocean coasts of Saudi Arabia
every map has its own unique beauty that
we haven't seen since Bad Company 2 the
same can also be said about the detail
and destruction each map has fortresses
turned inside out from bombings villages
torn to pieces by tank fire and mountain
tops covered an enemy shell fire all
equals to a surreal environment settings
that will pull you into the conflict and
won't let you go not that you would want
to of course some changes have been made
since the beta the horse for example no
longer has the wide range to hit and
kill your opponents so if you relied
heavily on running people over you might
be up for a surprise another thing too
is the assault class still carries the
majority of the explosives but now the
medic and support classes can do more
damage to vehicles which no longer
leaves a job to just one character a new
mode titled operations which is a cross
between Rush and conquest has players
battle it out to hold capture points and
fix locations on each section of the map
with attacking and defending teams with
the behemoths making a more important
role to play it's a mode that feels like
something we as battlefield vets have
been waiting for for a long time little
changes to audio and environment weather
also plays a part in the player to
player needs on a whole new level for so
long I wanted to relive those awesome
close call battles and fully destroyed
maps back in back company to battlefield
3 4 and hard lines failed to give me
that rush I missed but battlefield 1
feels like the game to keep me and my
friends busy for months to come if
you're a vet of the series but are on
the fence about jumping into this one
take it from me you will find the same
adrenaline rush shootout mayhem and
vehicle warfare the series has been
missing is there anything you want to
see or hope for in the months to come to
support battlefield one feel free to
leave your comments below and until next
time we'll see you on the battlefield
and keep it here on gamespot for all
your gaming needs
[Music]